aujourd'hui c'est pas nouveau le
problème de la tranquillité publique de
la sécurité
il se passe de la manière suivante il
faut faire de la prévention
au tout début il faut faire de la
dissuasion et il faut des sanctions
or la prévention c'est assez simple
c'est nous qui devons nous en occuper
c'est l'éducation c'est les parents
c'est les médiateurs
c'est l'éducation spécialisée tout ça ça
fait la prévention et puis il y à la
dissuasion la dissuasion c'est la
présence sur le terrain or nous manquons
de policiers l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur a pris un engagement auprès
de moi d'affecter 30 policiers
supplémentaires
la direction de la sécurité publique
urbaine à dijon donc j'attends que il y
à une suite à cela
et puis il ya la sanction derrière il
faut qu'elle soit rapide et immédiate
n'est pas reporté à six mois et des mois
un an ou deux ans
c'est pour ça que des fois y'a de la
comparution immédiate est que c'est très
bien côté de la comparution immédiate
et la sanction elle doit être exemplaire
s'il n'y a pas de sanction doute
courrier au garde des sceaux
si c'est repoussé elle n'a plus de
caractère d'exemplarité la sanction donc
voyez c'est toute une chaîne
d'où la nécessité d'écrire tout à la
fois ruiz d'intérieur monde aux
effectifs à la garde des sceaux pour
qu'elle fournisse des substituts
supplémentaire au procureur qui va
arriver en manque de personnel dans le
domaine de la justice et donc il faut
qu'on s'en préoccupe
dijon chenôve la métropole dijonnaise
est relativement calme par rapport aux
autres mais moi je veux pas que ça
dégénère et donc je sais qu'il faut se
saisir des sujets et il faut le faire
fermement je vais le dire à la préfète
il faut qu'on soit aidé par les pouvoirs
publics c'est pas nos communes
même avec nos policiers municipaux qui
je le rappelle n'ont même pas le droit
de faire des contrôles d'identité je les
demande et c'est pas nos policiers
municipaux qui peuvent faire respecter
la nuit la tranquillité des habitants
elle est indispensable c'est la police
nationale c'est son rôle elle le fait
bien
mais elle n'a pas les moyens de faire
mieux il faut qu'elles le fassent mur